انا ارى هنا عدد قليل او كميه قليله من
الخبز يحاول
المواطنون هنا الحصول على ما يمكن الحصول
عليه كما تشاهدون في هذه الجزئيه
ونسال ايضا كيف هم يدبرون حياتهم اليوميه
بالنسبه للحصول على الخبز خاصه يعتبر من
السلعه الاساسيه في مثل هذه الظروف والله
السودان ما يستاهل هذا اللي احنا خايفين
ده العشاء يا جماعه 120 جنيه العشاء ب 120
جنيه دقيق ما في مواد غذائيه ما في فنسال
الله انه يعني يلطف بالعباد يا اخي والله
العظيم يعني نسال الله انه يلطف بامر
الغائمين بامر هذه البلد يا الله يا اخي
دعني حاجه والله العظيم يعني غريب على
الشعب السوداني وغريب على السودان عامه
احنا والله العظيم والله متاسفين والله
الواحد كلمنا والله العظيم شكرا هذا يتحدث
عن الخبز وصل درجه عاليه من الاسعار كما
ان شحا النقود كذلك المصارف مغلقه يعني
الموا يجدون الصعوبه في ايجاد النقود التي
يستطعون شراء بها هذه المواد الغذائيه كما
ان الخدمات الرئيسيه المتعلقه بالمياه
والكهرباء بعض المواد الغذائيه مثلا بعض
الخضروات بعض الاشياء ولكنها برضو ايضا
يعني بها كثير من الصعاب وهم يتحدثون عن
هذه الظروف بشكل يعني فيه نوع من الصعوبه
كيف تعيشون وضعكم الان صعب صعب جدا صعب
تتخيل الحمد لله والشكر لله كله بيد الله
اكثر شيء يعني يواجهكم من صعوبات
اطفال خلاص لانه احنا تعودنا على الرغيف
اكثر شيء
البلد
الحافله دقيق ما في خبز ما في حاجات
الحاجات بقت غاليه من كيلو الطماطم ب 200
بقى ب 1200 والحمد لله غيته رضيانين بغض
ربنا انقلكم هذه المشاعر مشاعر المواطنين
الذي تعبر التي تعبر عن هذه الظروف الصعبه
وكذلك يعبرون عن صعوبه الحصول على
المواد الغذائيه والكهرباء والخدمات بصفه
عامه